-Hey, guys, it is time to take
a look at the stories
making headlines today
and weigh the good with the bad.
It's time for "Pros and Cons."
Here we go.
♪ Pros and Cons
and Pros and Cons ♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪ And Pros ♪
-Tonight we'll be taking a look
at the pros and cons of the...
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
-Yep, that's right,
the Centers for Disease Control
recently announced
some new rules and regulations
regarding the Omicron variant,
so let's look
at the pros and cons of the...
Here we go.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Oh.
Gotta try, right.
-Yeah, they tried.
You had a meth burrito.
[ Laughter ]
-I slipped up.
I had a meth burrito.
What's the problem?
-What are you going to do?
[ Laughter ]
What are you going to do?
It happens to everybody.
[ Mimicking chain saw ]
-Oh!
-"Thank you."
-I don't travel
with people like that.
-Is that a Milwaukee?
[ Sniff ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
What? Still?
[ Laughter and applause ]
"We don't know."
"Remove the item from the bag"?
-"Put it in the bag"?
-"Remove them first,
then put the bag back."
[ Laughter ]
-"Call cashier"?
-"Call cashier to check you out,
teach you how to use this"?
"Get a job at CVS"?
-What?
[ Laughter ]
-"Work four days a week
after your job...
-Oh, my gosh!
-...see if you like it.
-Yeah.
-It's fun.
It's a good family here at CVS."
-More receipts.
[ Laughter ]
-With all the receipts,
-think of all the coupons...
-Oh, my gosh!
-...things you can save."
Okay.
-Ah, CVS Care Card.
-"I want to give
to this charity"?
Yeah, sure, sure.
-Oh, sure.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
And then, do I pay for it now?
-"No."
-Yeah, paid. I'm all good.
Alright.
-[ Mimicking alarm ]
-No, I didn't steal anything!
[ Laughter ]
-What?!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-[ Both vocalizing ]
-That's how I get it out.
It's a different way to exhale.
-You just do that?
[ Laughter ]
Like that?
-No, I go --
-Oh really?
I go --
[ Laughter ]
-No, I go --
-Oh, that's good.
That's good.
-Yeah.
What do you do?
-Ahh!
[ As Jerry Lewis ] Boy!
[ Laughter ]
[ Indistinct ]
Meth burrito.
-Meth --
Ladies and gentlemen,
Meth Burrito!
[ Laughter ]
Monster truck comes out.
-Truck recently canceled.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-[ As Lewis ] Got it!
-And, finally...
[ Laughter and applause ]
There you go, everybody.
That's "Pros and Cons."